matt harvey will make the start
this will be his fourth start of the
year well look the sox
in the first inning the last two nights
have taken the lead it was a brayu's
two-run homer last night
edwin's sac fly on friday night and
edwin's the guy
that gets the opportunity here franco's
way off the third base he's getting a
big lead down to third
had a baby so harvey works around the
lead-off single
in the stolen base ultra reliable dallas
kykel
for the sox on the bound in his ninth
start of the year and
in the air left center eloy jimenez
against the sun and against robert and
luis
parks himself right out in front for
route number two
well i think he saw that eloy had some
trouble
looking straight up in the sun it's a
lot easier if you're coming across
and eloy didn't give him the look this
time he said if you got it you got it
got him looking strike three called
right there on the inside corner white
sox for the second time today of a
runner at third base
in this scoreless game at the top of the
third inning with one out
right side that's through the drawn in
infield and the sox strike first once
again grandahl an rbi
single sanchez scores rbi 17
and if you don't hit it at somebody with
the infield in they have
a lot a lot of room for base hits and
this one
through the right side blank socks in
field be playing in trying to cut the
rundown
at home monday i'm sure we'll have the
contact play
right side danny's coming home throw is
and time tag is there
danny mendick cuts down monday even with
that brilliant speed
pretty close play at the plate i think
they're going to probably take another
look at it we'll see if the leg got in
before the tag but
this is a contact play nice effort by
mendick
the question is i know the foot got
there but it might have been above the
plate
i think he's safe steve to me he looked
like he was safe
he was called out by ryan blakeney they
call him out and the socks will
absolutely take him wow hunter does your
second at-bat and that's a shot
up the middle that's off of sanchez
glove and now his throw
is going to sail in and out of the
royals dugout
and dozier's going to end up at second
base
they heads up in that dugout
dozier's at third but now with two down
and the batter will be bubba starling
and that one is lifted towards the
second baseman backhanded picked there
by mendic thrown across is not gonna be
in time yes it's gonna be in time
i didn't think abraham was able to keep
his foot on the bag
but he did and the call is out at first
base
and i don't believe that the royals can
challenge that because
they challenge the play at the plate it
is uh definitely not
going to be challenged we'll take
another look at it real quick here and a
brayer
falling toward the play made the catch
and actually did keep his foot on the
bag
and starling is out alberta here's
bizarro
i think robert's going here sometime in
the first
early sequence how about now
he is safe stolen base louise robert so
he's got a good
two-step jump and the swipe tag misses
him the call by dj rayburn
and that would be a huge add-on run
if no mark can drive him home
nomar lifts it left center field well
hit into the alleyway robert's going to
score easily he could backstroke home
and nomar mazara doubles him there tune
up and socks
no mars hit it three times on the button
today
a single a fly out and a double and this
time he takes it the other way on a
slider that slider is the middle of the
plate
finally gets hernandez in trouble and
it's no mar mazara driving home a huge
run that's his eighth of the year giving
the sox a two run lead
and the bases are indeed loaded for tim
anderson
and holland strikes him out with the
bases loaded so dallas kykel came out to
warm up
in the sixth inning and now he is coming
out of the ball game so
dallas goes walking through the tunnel
and
james mccann talked to him briefly but
dallas kykel went out to the mound he
was
getting himself ready to get loose and
then
left and now jimmy cordero to the hill
for the socks
so first and third two down for mcbroom
on oh and two
it's in the zone upstairs strike three
didn't mean to
that'll do jimmy 19-game hitting streak
it's the second longest streak in his
career he had a 21-game streak back in
his rookie season of 2014.
and abraham lines that in the center
field of base hit make that a 20-game
hitting streak for jose abreu
as he stops the first base and grand all
stops at second first and second
and nobody out here in the seventh
inning two-nothing white sox
well you said he needed to get it going
and he did right there
here's encarnacion of the plate he's
over three
breaking ball hammered deep left field
and this is way out of here there's your
separation
take a bath in it five-nothing socks
here comes the parrot
a stimulating three-run home run for
encarnacion in the offense
that's his eighth home run and his rbi
total
jumps from 11 to 14. the long ball in
attendance
sox take advantage of it and suddenly
the lead is a whole lot more comfortable
oliveira's right-handed hitter with
bubba starling at first there's a swing
and a ball
struck pretty well down the left field
line way back there and that ball is
gone
into the chicago bullpen a two-run homer
by edward olavares it comes on the first
pitch
paul lavares with a two run shot down
the left field line
in a game in which it's been all white
sox to this point the royals on the
board now it's five to two
so here's yasmani grandahl two and two
breaking ball down the left field side
oh that's a great at bat from grandau
he plugs it into the corner and scores
sanchez just
threw his bat at the ball and sliced it
down the line for a 6-2 lead
two runs driven in 18 for the year for
yasmani
and carnacion at the plate
edwin up the middle that trickles
through and a big run to add
to seven now for the sox and a five run
lead
can maybe alleviate a little pressure on
the bullpen saw dyson
come in to play left field last night as
eloy
triggers this one into left center field
and rolling up the alley way it'll grab
a popsicle as it nestles against the
wall
and dyson scores to make it eight to two
on a summer day in kansas city
eloy doesn't wait around a long time he
just
takes it into the gap dyson scores
easily this is a slider that's down and
out over the plate
wisconsin native alex mcrae bidding for
a final strike
he's got it strike three and the sox
sweep kansas city in
four at kauffman stadium for the first
time
in 23 years